so today
we're going on from zero dimensions to
one dimensions and we're talking about
line defects
in order to understand what they mean
we're going to contextualize it in terms
of
stress strain curve so we'll talk about
that
and and all of this is called the
dislocation so that's our
goal for today now on monday after
lecture
actually a student came up to me and
asked a really good question
and it was related to the hume rotary
rule so these are
um remember on monday we talked about
point defects zero dimensional right so
you you have a disturbance
a localized disturbance in the lattice a
vacancy you take it out
uh you can have that occur in
a material that's ionic right not a
metal but maybe an ionic material and
then
then you got to think about charge
neutrality shocky franco
and then we talked about substitutional
defects which would be where
you take an atom out of the lattice and
you put another one in and and hume
rothery i mentioned had come up with
some empirical observations now
and and so i listed these and and you
know
so he studied a class of medals and came
up with these sort of general guidelines
and as with so many things that we've
learned so far
you know these are general rules that
get broken sometimes so i want
so i went so the the question the
student asked is very good and said well
how can you
if the valence of something you're
trying to substitute into something else
has to be you know the same or higher
how does p doping work how does it how
does a p-type
semiconductor work that's a really good
question right because
the valence is lower by definition
that's how you make it p-type
ah so my response was well because hume
rothery was kind of designed around
metals
yeah i'm not sure how much of these
apply to semiconductors
although for semiconductors you do want
to make sure the sizes are similar
at the very least but that got me
thinking and so i went and i read
uh some papers last night uh here's one
on the valence effects uh and relative
stabilities valency effects
and so this is from the 80s and i just
wanted to cite something here as i
thought
so here they say um almost a half
century ago so that's hume rothery
right okay so it's the 80s so the 30s uh
pioneered the study of the effect of
valency on metal alloy phase equilibria
they found
that a lower valence metal like silver
had only a very small solubility and a
higher valence element like antimony but
that the solubility of the reverse was
large so that's where that rule came
from
and here's the next part of this paper i
want to share uh
although the relative illness works well
for that select group of allies it does
not
apply to the periodic table as a whole
so this other guy looked at 607
different systems and found that 22
percent of the time the valency rule
works
and 27 percent of the time it violated
the rule
and honestly i'm not sure we can call it
a rule anymore
if more times than not it's violated
this is like a new thing for me
so uh so you know that is
uh just to say that this rule uh
probably uh is is really conditional
on the specific elements you're talking
about i think the much more
important ones are these three here okay
the valency rule
uh certainly depends on the system and
all of the hume rotary observations were
empirical
okay this is important to keep in mind
general guidelines
meant to be broken more than half the
time apparently
okay so where were we right monday but
thank you for that question it's great
question
maybe it gave me some great reading last
night materials
um uh okay zero dimensional
monday one dimensional today there we
are okay
so that's the focus now the story today
starts at mit it starts at mit in the
1940s
because there were these two students
there they are
harold hinman and george burr
and mit students back then were a little
bit older
i guess okay so those guys so they were
in an mit lab
and they were they were trying to study
how parachutes break how does a
parachute break
because why is that an important
question because you don't want it to
break
right and and it's one of these things
where you want it to
never break like you really want like a
hun almost
so they were studying why it breaks so
they were taking a parachute and pulling
it apart
there it broke take another kind of
material pull that apart
it broke this one didn't but it's too
heavy
right they were studying the
relationship of the mechanical
breaking to the material of the
parachute
so i love that logo there that's the two
of them in the lab at mit
pulling on a parachute right they just
have like a tug of war with a parachute
but the problem was that there was no
instrument at the time that could give
them
the sensitivity to the force
that they were pulling there was no
instrument that could capture
what they needed to make a better
parachute
so being mit students they built their
own
they built their own and they added a
whole bunch of electronics
into this instrument and that is where
the name comes from it's an instrument
that had a lot of electronics for the
time
instron is the name of their company
instron is now
synonymous with stress strain curves
right so you go into any university any
company you look at how if they need to
measure something
like whether an egg breaks or not at
what force
uh it's an instron machine right it's an
instrument machine there it is
same logo okay and and because
those machines give you the most
accurate
and and and uh well uh calibrated
a description of the force that you're
applying right
on this material as you and you can
apply it very very slowly so these are
very common machines
to look at at force versus
uh the force you apply to take it how
much distance
right okay so we're going to talk about
that today
um now we're not going to talk about it
in terms of
eggs we're going to talk about it in
terms of wire
and so there's a wire it's kind of a
little hard to see there there it is
there's another instrom machine
this is a red one okay and here they are
and they're looking at this wire and
this wire is some material maybe it's
copper
it's aluminum and they're saying how
does this thing
what happens to this thing as i as i
just pull it
yeah in small increments what is the
force that i have to put on this to pull
it a certain amount now that
is an important graph and it's so
important
that i really want you guys to
understand this graph
because it is the way that mechanical
properties of materials
are first uh often analyzed
and it's a plot of the stress
which is equal to the force per area
versus the string
which is equal to the change in the
length
divided by the original length now what
do i mean by that well let's take a wire
here's the wire
there's that wire in there okay so
here's a wire
and i'm going to apply a force this way
that's what the instron is doing
all right so there's some force being
applied to it and oh
and there's some area of the wire and
there was some original length
okay this is called a stress strain
curve
it's the force divided by the area over
which you're applying it
yeah that you apply to get the thing to
stretch a certain amount
now the those mit students
were also very smart they knew
that many materials as you first start
stretching them
the bonds between the atoms are kind of
elastic
right what does that mean well it means
that if i if i stretch a little bit it
goes back
when it starts a little bit more it goes
back they're like springs
so when you think about the deformation
of that wire and many other materials
you've got in this elastic
regime and that means that it's
reversible
as i just said reverse the bull
and the displacement so it's reversible
displacement if i stretch it
it goes back reversible displacement
only occurring
under some applied force applied
force so if this is an elastic
you know stretch if i stretch this
material elastically and i'll let it go
and it goes back it's like a spring
hooke's law is going to apply
right so so hook's law applies right so
you know
f equals k x or a minus kx
did you compress it or you know okay
hooke's law
okay so so that means that if i start
pulling on this and i start here
so there's no stress and there's no
strain
right and if i start pulling on this
then i'm going to get a straight line
like that okay so that's going to be
the elastic
regime how about these mit students
the thing is they knew something else
they knew that for a lot of materials
it didn't keep going like this it didn't
keep going
linearly in this sort of a nice elastic
spring way they knew that
either the thing broke completely
right or it deformed or it started
deforming and that is called
the plastic regime oh we're coming to
plastics later
and this is a permanent shape change
permanent shape change
and you you can imagine if i'm going to
permanently
change the shape of a material it's got
to be ductile right okay so so if it's
something that's going to
break all right remember we talked about
it like with ionic versus metallic
right those metal those doing it again
the sea of electrons
allows those metals to be ductile right
uh and and that has to do with the
bonding with the electronic structure
if you want a material to be able to
change shape permanently and not crack
you need that ability to be ductile so
there's a plastic regime
and that makes this
change dramatically so what happens now
is
if i if i keep stretching it beyond this
elastic regime
the stress strain curve is no longer
linear and in fact it might look
something like this
until at some point so this would be the
plastic
part where it's literally deforming it's
changing its shape
and then finally i've stretched it to
the point where it fractures so that's
called the fracture point
you just can't pull it anymore
you just can't pull it anymore and and
they're studying parachutes but they
knew that these
there were a lot of surprises out there
there's a lot of complexity in this
and they needed to understand this
regime and this regime
in order to really engineer the
parachute to make it better
they had to get that data and there were
no instruments that could
that could move it and measure it and
calibrate it carefully enough
and by the way you know this was also
this plastic deformation that happens
this plastic this this permanent shape
change but without breaking
no that it happens very early on
so so there were people working for
example with aluminum
saying well i predict given the bond
strength of aluminum
i predict a certain mechanical strength
that aluminum could go to
and then they find that it starts
deforming a hundred times
lower than that a hundred times lower
why because it go it enters into this
plastic regime
it doesn't stay elastic so what i want
to talk about today
is how it so i hope i've convinced you
how important this is and i'll have a
why this matters
on that as well but but what i want to
talk about today
is how these one-dimensional defects
fit in with this right how these
one-dimensional defects fit in and in
fact
they explain it all they explain it all
this is what the wire looks like when
you stretch a wire and you look at it
carefully
it's not just like a little bit longer
it has these very set
features that occur it's not just a
forming in any random way it's deforming
in a very specific way
it's deforming in a very specific way
and so what i want to
talk about is that way and
what deformation okay the plastic
deformation mechanism
is is called slip mechanism
is called slip
that leads to plastic deformation
and it leads to that picture and it
leads
to the data
that they got from the instron machine
so where does it come from okay this is
a 2d picture of a lattice this is a 2d
picture of a lattice
and and so you can imagine
what i've done oh i'm going to hand this
out i love this i can just sit and look
at this
you know this is so cool this is a cubic
uh uh sim you know you can think about
it as like a simple cubic lattice here's
a plane
right uh here's another plane right here
there's another one
look at that yellow one there right so
many planes
right all right so you could i got lost
there
just thinking about it and and i'm going
to the other side
you could you could get lost too um
that's one of the planes okay that's one
of the planes imagine it
now you notice here i've got hanging out
because why not
oh why not it because there's no other
possibility
because vacancies always exist
as we learn monday they cannot not exist
so there's one right there cool there's
an interstitial
point defect there's a substitutional
point defect that's all from monday
they're just hanging out but here's what
we're talking about now look at this
i want to take this little symbol this t
and i want to look at the lines that
come down from it so there they are
so these are now planes okay these are
planes
these are crystal graphic planes and and
now look at the other side of it
and notice those same planes are
following
go go to the seat to the left there you
see how that's now
a plane a plane so this this is actually
lined up from the outside
in it's lined up it's lined up right
here
i put an extra one in you see that
that's an extra plane that doesn't go
all the way through if it went all the
way through it wouldn't be an extra
plane
right so it's sandwiched in here
and then here it continues over there
that one kind of goes like that and that
one kind of goes like that
and then they kind of go back to the
normal planes i have inserted
a half if you want to think about it of
a plane
right there look at that that is called
a dislocation that is a one-dimensional
defect it's a dislocation
that is caused by putting an extra plane
that stops somewhere and where it stops
you draw a little t
in the crystal right this stops oh let's
go with ximena come on
there we go we'll go back to this so
that is called
a dislocation that is called the
dislocation
that is the 1d defect
it's called a dislocation
it's a line defect
formed by
what is essentially a misregistry of
atoms
that gives you an extra plane
now you can already see that if i put a
line defect in there it's messing with
the bonds right
at this at this place here here the
bonds just kind of go along they go
along and then all of a sudden
i've got a kind of misregistry now
because of that
dislocation because of that dislocation
so okay one way to look at it is with
the model another way is just get ears
of corn
and it's really i did this last night i
actually
i i got ears of corn i'm not actually
that's really true
and i looked inside this isn't from
there
this is from the internet but but there
it is
right the corn needed to grow another
row
and so it it's not going to grow a half
kernel well actually it could it does
sometimes but here it grew
another full row of kernels and there it
is there's an there's a dislocation it's
just
it's very similar to what we're looking
at
now there are two types of dislocations
this one where you insert an extra plane
in this way is called an
edge dislocation there's another type of
dislocation that we won't talk about in
this class called the screw dislocation
you can look it up it's a different type
of line defect
but the one that we're concerned with is
called an edge dislocation and it's
described exactly in this way and the
way you
you note it on a on a in a drawing an
atomic scale drawing like this
by putting that upside down t where the
edge
is okay an
edge dislocation edge dislocations in
corn
now you can actually see these things
and on these models
the dislocations look very nice and
uniform and
and you can hold it and look at it but
in reality
here's an actual video of dislocations
notice these are groups of dislocations
notice
these are 1d line defects they're places
where you've got
this extra plane notice that they're
they're all over the place
they're not just straight they they bend
around in the crystal
and they move and the movement is
critical
the movement is critical that's what's
going to get us back to this
the movement that this is the defect and
then
the movement is what gets us this okay
so let's take a look so here's an here's
an example this is a piece of material
that under the microscope is being
pulled
watch what happens those things are
moving
they're forming they're ending they're
reforming they're interacting with each
other
that one didn't but whatever and they're
spreading out they're growing
those dislocations those dislocations
and their movement
is why this doesn't crack it's why this
can move
this can bend it's why
this point is a hundred times lower
than you might have thought okay
and that can be understood by thinking
about the bonds that can be understood
by thinking about the bonds
here's a sequence of pictures okay now
uh so so this this is the dislocation
this is the dislocation you see it there
okay
now what i'm doing is i'm pushing um
or just maybe let's let's not push yet
we'll do that on the next slide
for now i'm just i'm just watching it
move here you see it moving
okay there it is how does it move well
here's a model
there's a dislocation and you can see
that if i
if i take this bonding area around here
and i connect this atom to there and
then you kind of start pushing there's a
strain field around there
and then you kind of push it over you
might be able to move it over
to there right what and maybe you could
keep on doing that
and keep on moving it over and over
until it gets all the way to that end
all the way to the end of the material
right
here is a super uh uh
polished high detail animation of that
process
okay here it is i'm starting over here
and watch the dislocation there it is
there it is
and it's moving and it's moving and
those bonds are breaking
let's watch that again okay here it is
there it formed
but why did it form because
you see what happened is i took this
material
and i applied a force to it yet i went
back to the wire
and i did this or maybe i did this
and and the material said okay hold on
how can i respond to this thing
well either i could respond elastically
and all my bonds could stretch
but i'm getting to this kind of
uncomfortable place here
right or a dislocation could come in
and allow me to translate a whole set of
bonds
over by one so i'm applying a force
right to this material you can think
about as like a force maybe on the
bottom
going you know so
watch what happens look at this i've got
a little extra room here
okay now watch what happens there it is
there it is
okay and i have moved
the whole top row of atoms over the
whole top three rows
over by one so i have transformed this
so that the force
if you think about the force on the
bottom could be applied that way and the
force is stopped that way
the atoms get to a certain point where
it's like no my elasticness
is i'm not sure i want to go anymore
but a dislocation comes in and saves the
day
and it allows that to happen because
here's the alternative here's the
alternative
if i want that same translation to
happen that same slip
i would have had to break all the bonds
at once if i didn't have a dislocation
this is what would
okay there's a dislocation one bond at a
time
one bond at a time or the much much
harder
ask especially since there's like 10 to
the 20 something of these
is to break them all at once there it is
bam
that's why that doesn't happen that it
just takes too much energy
but if i can just call up a dislocation
to the rescue
i can translate an entire set of atoms
with much much much less energy right
you see that
so the dislocation moving
is what allows plastic deformation
it's what allows these atoms to slide
over one another
it is what enables this region
to be there and it's what defines it
it's a very important point here
oh he got a goodie bag that's okay
was he in the class it doesn't matter we
share
if you guys have friends that just came
in took one
if you guys have friends that need goody
bags we are here to help
i will never turn down a goody bag
there is a plane here that's moving on
another plane
there is a plane that's moving on
another plane and it's doing it only
because of that dislocation that one
dimensional defect
now that is slipping so it's called a
slip plane
it's called a slip plane and it's the
plane
along which
the dislocation moves
this location
okay we've got phone going on there
now i want to make a really important
point here because
what the dislocation is allowing what
this defect is allowing you to do
is resolve forces
that's what you're doing i i'm putting
this force on i'm
see i'm putting the stuck in the
instrument i'm pulling the wire
and and the material is like hold on i
gotta respond to this
how can i do yeah
yes and i will come back to that it's
this plane
it's where's the model who's got the
model
is that the dislocation model it's the
plane
where the dislocation comes in and can
move
okay why because that's the plane
that is by motion of the dislocation
that's the plane that's slipping along
another one
by exactly this animation and i'll talk
about the slip plane in a minute
also more about it
but so what this motion what this
slip plane what these these movements of
the planes allow
is is it allows you to resolve an
applied force
so i come at this material with a force
and i resolve it it's resolved
at the atomic
at the atomic level and i'll finish this
at the atomic level
along that slip plane
that's what it does the
the instron pulls or i pull
with you know on the parachute like the
logo
and and then either the material is
going to break
or maybe it's just in that elastic
region and then it will all go all the
way back or it's going to deform
and if it deforms what's it doing it's
it's feeling the force
and it's trying to resolve it and it
resolves it by those
those dislocations moving okay planes
move on top of each other
well okay so let's go back to this plane
what plane
is it if i look at the at the planes
which are somewhere out there
you can imagine that if i'm i've got all
those planes
and they're looking at at the instrument
and the force being applied to me
which one is going to do the slipping
well you can imagine that this with a
very simple analogy
you know if i push on something if i
push on a rope
what does it do well it kind of curls up
it doesn't do too much
it doesn't move right but if i really
want to try to resolve
force i got to move those atoms right
and so so you want but if i push on a
stick and not a rope then the stick just
all moves
right so so the plane that is going to
move
that is going to move across another
plane is going to be the most
dense the closest pact it's going to be
the closest pact
so the slip plane
let's write it here
slip plane slip plane and i'll i'll give
you an example
in a minute slip plane closest packed
or highest
planar density right
because then i'm pushing on the stick in
the material i've got sticks and ropes
defined by the plane you can see it over
there some of those planes
they're beautiful the yellow one but it
doesn't have that many atoms per
area so if i try to move that one it's
not a very
it's not as strong of a plane to move
and to resolve my forces at the atomic
scale with so i'm always going to go for
that
strongest plane okay
so that's the slip plane now
a great analogy for this is the rug
so so if you're helping people move or
you're
setting up your own rug and you get it
and you put down the
the rug base like that and then you put
it down you're like ah
i missed it by a foot i got it wrong
this rug weighs rugs are really heavy
you said you pick it up you're like oh
i'll just move it
and you call a friend and you both pick
it up and you're like this is like a
thousand pounds
who knew it's really a pain
and so then you think about dislocations
and you think about how a material
would would handle this situation and
they say well if i just
make a little dislocation like a little
crinkle there
and i move that think about how much
effort it takes to move that
instead not much make a little crinkle
and then you move it
and then you move it doesn't take much
force to do that
it takes a lot less than picking up the
whole rug right
that's the motion of a dislocation we
just talked about the plane that it is
but which direction which way should you
move it
and and so this is the second part so
you have the
you have the slip plane the closest pack
or highest planar density
and you also have the slip direction
the slip direction is the other part
which way does it go
i've got i've got the closest pack plane
which way should it go
well for this you can see from the
experiments and when you look at the
wire again
if i take a copper wire and i pull it
and i look at it with my eyes
it doesn't it just looks like the
uniform wires and stretch but now i
magnify it
this is what you see okay
so you can see that there are very
definite directions
these are this is actually all the same
direction
so that's a slip plane and there's a
there's a direction
that it slides i like
i think this can be understood
i love this picture because i love ping
this is ping-pong balls and you guys can
do these uh these
experiments yourself you put a bunch of
ping-pong balls in a row
and then measure the force that it takes
to slide it depending on whether
they're closely packed or not but this
is a little counter-intuitive sometimes
when you first see it but it makes sense
the more densely packed
the plane is the easier it is
for one set of atoms to slide across the
other
the easier it is so you can kind of feel
it right
if i have to let this one uh and they
showed it just by angle at which it
would slide on an old i kind of like the
idea of two people
you know kind of going in there and and
here you'd have to apply more
force to make that one slide than this
one
yeah and you can see it again with this
super precise
because in tight animation there it is
one of them and there's the other one
look at how much more work you got to do
to get that thing to go
over and over right no if you've got a
high density of atoms
it's actually easier to slide it's
easier to slide
because you've got more bonds right and
so so i'm not like having to fully break
a bond before i get to the next one
right so that makes so the slip
direction then the slip direction
is going to be the uh the closed pack
direction the the highest
density direction so it's also
the closed pack so i've got an example
there close pack direction
um so notice this would be like
you know a direction a vector
and this is a plane well that's jogging
some memories
of understanding crystals by their
miller planes and directions
right so just you know if we say well
what would this be for say
fcc there's an fcc crystal
there's an fcc lattice so if i if i had
say fcc as an example
um well okay so let's see if i can
really quickly oh boy here we go
there it is and
here are the face atoms there we go
okay that's part of the outer part of
scc three of the faces
and now okay but if i take a 1
0 plane so so let's take the
10 plane then i've got that
remember i've got these atoms on the
corner why did i draw that so much
bigger
let's not do that right that would be
like the 100 plane
and this one you know this might be the
usual lattice constant a
well you could also look at the one
one o plane here it is the one one o
plane
uh that would look like this and
this okay that would be the 1-1-0 this
is just bringing back memories
i know good ones i know good ones
here is the 1-1-1 plane
and here we now okay so here we've got
this one
this one and this one
do you see what in an fcc
metal or crystal which plane
is going to slip and along which
direction but you can you can get that
now
because you could calculate the planar
densities
in which case is is the the packing
of atoms in which of these planes is it
the highest
right oh well you got to know the number
of atoms so
you know so how many atoms are in this
two
how many atoms are in this oh why a
quarter a quarter
i'm just counting in the in the unit
cell
of the plane okay so quarter a quarter
quarter quarter
one it only counts
in the plane if the plane goes right
through the atom
right here in the 110
i've got a quarter a quarter quarter
quarter okay that's one
plus a half a half two
i've got two atoms in that plane two you
know effectively two atoms in that plane
yeah what about here oh boy uh okay a
sixth a sixth a sixth right
you see it from the geometry it's a
triangle and so that's like a half from
those corners
plus a half a half a half two
i've got the same number
of atoms in those planes of the unit
cell of those
of those planes drawn within these unit
cell boxes
but but they're different planar
densities they're different planar
densities
now because the area here the area
is equal to a squared in this case
it's equal to root 2 a squared in this
case so it's larger
same atoms larger area that's not going
to have a higher packing than that
and now i get to have really a lot of
fun with triangles and thinking about
like the height
here and stuff like that and the area of
this one
is equal to root three
over two a squared
less than one
that's going to have the highest planar
density
you know it right that's going to have
the highest planar density
so that's a you know so that's a
connection now so you can connect now
what we've learned about miller planes
about crystallography to this simple
kind of uh uh you know calculations of
density
to this incredibly important behavior of
materials
plastic deformation because now you know
how that's going to plastically deform
it's going to deform along its closest
pack
closest packed plane and you can also
look at the directions and it's
it's shown here that the slip direction
will be along one of those
that's the highest density direction
the 110 so it's going to slip along one
of those directions
okay good slip plane it's a plane
plus this together combined
these are called slip systems
the slip plane and the direction
that's called the slip system okay now
um there's there's another thing that
happens with dislocations that's
so cool and so important to
materials and to the things we want to
do with materials
um and it has to do with the fact that
like i said the dislocations
come in and
and they come in and they can be a total
mess and entanglement
so by the way how did it come in in the
first place if i started with a perfect
crystal
where did it come from how could there
be
a dislocation it can come in from the
edge
right you've got an edge there there can
be a mismatch
and i call it up i need a dislocation
or i'm going to break boom comes in from
the edge comes in from the edge
they come to the rescue this
is a simulation of exactly that
done by the chair of the department of
civil uh in the
civil engineering department marcus
buehler
a simulation he did some years ago but
he's modeling the dislocations that's
what you're going to see here
as a piece of metal is cracked watch
this watch them come in
it's saying i need you help me and there
they go
okay now look at what hap there's so
many of them forming and forming and now
tangling
and tangling and tangling then he's
going to zoom in it's very cool
those are dislocations like we saw in
the experiments but this is a computer
simulation of them they're still kind of
tingling here they go
they come in they get called in to
relieve the atomic force
to release and let the material slip
yeah but there's something that happens
now
there's something that happens right
because now we go back to the rug
we go back to the rug and look at what's
happened i'm
going along and i did the calculation i
don't want to lift it it's too heavy but
i'm going to create a little dislocation
and move it along
and i come across someone else's
dislocation here
look at this i'm trying to roll mine and
there's another one there
what's going to happen
but i can't go anymore i'm blocked
i'm blocked so so when dislocations
tangle up
you can imagine now it prevents
dislocations
from moving but you said dislocation is
moving is what gives me the plastic
regime
so as i introduce dislocations
i prov i make it so that it's harder for
dislocations to move
right there's actually a name for that
there's a name for that
because it really changes the mechanical
properties
it's called cold hardening or work
hardening or strain hardening
sorry cold work cold working so work
hardening
or sometimes strain hardening
oh why is it called hardening
because you're literally making this
material harder
you you know what's happened is i've
taken away
ductility so i've made it more brittle
i've taken away the plastic deformation
it can't do as much plastic deformation
because that only happens by motion of
dislocations and i'm locking them in
but i'm letting it maybe go a little
farther in how much it can elastically
deform
right maybe now once it gets to here
it says you know what i you know okay
i've got all these dislocations in there
um it's not letting me plastically
deform so i'll keep elastically
deforming
i'll just keep a lot but that gets you
up to much higher stresses
it gets you up to much higher stresses
with elastic deformation
and so this is a plot look at that
that's called the oh i should have put
that
down there let me label that because
that's a pretty important point i
labeled the fracture point
this is the yield point there it is the
yield strength
right that's called the yield
because it's where it yields to plastic
deformation
okay right now so here you go you've got
some steel
you've got some brass and you've got
some copper and these this is plotting
look at that
this is the percent cold work cold work
is work hardening
work hardening is adding dislocations
on purpose on purpose so that what
so that i increase the yield strength so
that this material can
go in tight can elastically deform now
up to higher
and higher and higher strengths right
this is it and but but the ductility
goes down when you bend a paper clip
don't you go and tell anybody it's
because of heat that it breaks
that's not why a paper clip breaks it
gets hot and warm
you bend it back and forth it breaks
because you are putting dislocations
into it
and you're making it more brittle in
fact if you heated it up
you would anneal those out and make it
more ductile
again that's how you get rid of the
dislocations you got to heat it back
up it makes it brittle the ductility
goes down okay why does this matter well
this is one reason
if you don't plan your cold work
carefully
you might make the material too brittle
you wanted it to be so hard because this
was such an important ship
and it was going to be a big deal and
the launch was really exciting and then
it cracks in half
the entire ship why because you didn't
look up
what dislocations mean you didn't take
309.1
that's why that's a pretty big crack
but the the the main why this matters oh
i couldn't help it
i am a big fan of wind
wind energy is growing and growing and
it's it's it's such a great resource
it's such a great national resource
here's the global uh capacity and
this is install capacity for wind uh
turbines
um but see this is a mechanical
materials problem that you are now
equipped to think about more deeply
right um because you see you can
you can do a lot of different
experiments on those turbines so the
turbine
so the blades here are critical you can
imagine that
you want them to be light but but if
they're too light there may not be
strong enough and then how do they need
to be strong because you've got
huge amounts of wind coming at them
and it turns out you need to hit just
the right balance
of elastic deformation
before it goes into some plastic regime
you need to hit just the right balance
of ductility
so here's for example these are some
simulations here are some experiments on
a new
material for a wind turbine blade and
then you put it out there
and and look at what happens ice by the
way this ice
comes off at hundreds of miles an hour
in chunks
these farmers are not happy about that
seriously but those are bugs
those are bugs so actually bugs in
wind turbine blades is a serious problem
how do you clean
bugs off of it because it dramatically
changes the aerodynamics and the
efficiency
it also can damage the blade itself
so there's all sorts of work going on
how do you make bug proof
wind turbine blades okay we'll now just
spray it with something ah but then does
it have the right
plastic different what does it have the
right yield point or is it just going to
crack
right and and by the way it's got to
have
five times 10 to the ninth cycles before
it can fail
that's like the metric so that's a
pretty big ask of a material
it all comes down to understanding this
curve
and and in the broader sense of
materials
this to me is a very exciting ask
why because if you look at a plot
of the density of materials okay heavy
light good kilograms per meter cubed and
and the young's modulus now this is a
measure of
of the strength of the material right
it's a measure of how much
strain you could put on the material
before it breaks or
it goes through deformation but look at
this different materials are here
rubbers foams okay foams have
relatively low young's modulus but
they're really light that could be good
uh up here you've got metals and alloys
ceramics
you've got polymers in here but but
notice
i've got so many different applications
and needs in the applications
and i've got this plot where i've got
nothing here and nothing here
even though if i could fill this out
and dial up any stress strain curve
for any density or young's modulus you
can make a big difference in a lot of
different applications so i think this
is a great
a great challenge have a good night see
you guys on friday
you